all right let's talk about smart kids
and drugs because it turns out that if
you're doing drugs as a kid you're
probably going to be smarter in real
life studies show a correlation between
high childhood IQs and getting high
we're talking about weed yes using data
from the 1958 national child development
study researchers published a report
last year that found that children who
have higher IQs were more likely to use
illegal drugs later in life again I
believe this was mostly about weed does
this surprise you guys at all it seems
to me that oh I know I think I know some
smart people and I know a lot of people
we know you're smart and you're
intelligent also smart whether I use the
same word twice know are you gonna be
curious not everybody who's brilliant
like me but no I mean I think that many
people are curious at one point want to
you know do something to get the juices
flowing
yeah Potts the Grays drug in the world
except when I fell out my life insurance
policy but it is the great I don't even
know what you're talking about the
character of Andy Kindler might know
right and they do some sweet damage at
Hugo's tacos when I'm high yeah
beautiful damage oh my god I'm keeping
them in business for at least another
four years but I think you're right I
think that a lot of really smart kids
feel under stimulated they get bored in
school they're bored by their peers
because they just they don't connect
with them like they'd like to you
because they're they're not on the same
IQ level so they look for other ways to
self-medicate other ways to feel
stimulated and they get high well it
also alcohol to me well I don't drink
because I'm a Jewish alcohol syndrome I
just get sleepy so I don't think alcohol
for most people to stimulate you like
your mind so I think things like pot are
different because they actually get you
thinking or eating right so is this one
of those things where it shows how
stupid our war on drugs is that we love
weed in we love we do with all these
other hard drugs when in fact and then
people see people stoned and not really
doing anything evil and then you don't
the kids can't make the connection that
there's a difference between drugs so
they see that weed is kind of cool and
that you know these other drugs are
probably
no anyway all this stuff you know a lot
of that stuff was political to because
you know a hippie smoke pot so it was it
was in the interest of the government to
oh you know to make those type of things
even more illegal well at the time with
the best you know after-school specials
and growing pains with the coke party oh
yeah and the we were like well whatever
it's my parents coke and it was like to
be continued and there's no music at the
end of the world but there were so many
of these sitcoms that villainized weed
and I wasn't just saying no club and
dare and I never got it because he's
pretty great right it's a victimless
drug but that's it's not a drug I mean
I'm thinking he's going sorry what he
made is that I mean it's more and more
information is coming out that says it's
very now that people can be addicted to
anything and some people just do get
spaced out but it's you know it's it's
helpful in not just in chemotherapy it's
supposed to in many ways I think it's
actually going to be found to be
positive for the well do you guys see
this the last week dr. Sanjay Gupta on
CNN had a mayor Copa because after all
this time of railing against weed he
finally is yeah he's he's been against
even medicinal marijuana and he finally
now did this special saying he
apologized he actually said I'm sorry
and now he's pro weed right and for a
country and especially a state that is
so woefully under water when it comes to
money why isn't it just a recreational
thing that we can legalize tax the [ __ ]
out of it we don't care what the by in
any way yeah yeah but you don't want to
make the taxes too high because in the
black market kicks in I just have to
check with Nancy Snyderman and all this
you know what I'm saying dr. Nancy
Snyderman because she's on NBC and she
doesn't know anything
yeah should we not listen are you saying
we shouldn't listen to doctors on
television they're ours they're
absolutely I like Robert Bozell bet I
was one of my favorites he doesn't he
has a problem with the hands he's I was
like but all these people who said like
every two years ago salts terrible for
you and then then they find out salt is
not bad for you and all these people are
the conventional wisdom junkies that's
all they do is tell you what the
conventional is I'm glad I'm glad Sanjay
Gupta is coming around
that sanjay's thing is he probably knew
this all along but three years ago it
wasn't cool to say you're down with weed
now he sees the times changing so CNN's
like a Gupta let's let's come around on
the weed thing don't you think I mean
but I think maybe he didn't know he
wasn't even knew enough about it because
he doesn't seem like a guy who got high
Gupta yeah but maybe it's really that
something he didn't pay attention to so
he bought the the line on it you really
think those CNN guys aren't just you
don't think Wolf Blitzer was taking a
bond on the camera he's in a situation
room under can't play around there yeah
that's a lot of pressure to be at work
in a place called The Situation Room but
that's a whole other thing okay guys
thank you for watching thank Andy
Kindler thank Gina Grad subscribe it's
down there I should have said it twenty
other times now get out there and have
sex do some drugs pay attention to Egypt
watch al Jazeera and go drink Coke and
there was one more what was the other
one a lot of and if we're going into
comedy you're gonna make a boatload of
dough ok subscribe we'll do it again
next week
[Music]